this is the moment an armed police
response team arrives on streatham high
road to find terrorist sudesh a man
dying on the pavement seconds after
another armed team of covert officers
opened fire to stop his knife attack
discovering what looks like a suicide
vest the officers back off
ushering members of the public to safety
two of the armed surveillance officers
are seen here in the seconds after they
shot the 20-year-old maintaining a safe
distance as they keep their guns trained
on the fatally injured terrorist
this is a man just 30 minutes before the
attack on the 2nd of february last year
leaving his nearby probation hostel
following him as he headed towards
streatham high road a surveillance team
of nine officers on foot in cars and on
a motorbike
authorities were convinced the young
extremist posed a very significant
threat to the public
after wandering up and down streatham
high road he suddenly ducked into a
discount store and stole a nine inch
long kitchen knife
bolting out of the shop chased by some
of the surveillance officers he launched
his attack stabbing two members of the
public
he was seen on store surveillance
cameras running past pursued by the
officers
at one point turning around and heading
directly for those officers
one of them known only as bx75
said
i thought he was going to stop me and
kill me certainly seriously injure me he
was so close to me that i was an
immediate fear of my life
i fired a shot in his chest area
the other officer bx 87 struggled to
compose himself as he described how
sudesha man lunged towards him with his
knife raised
the officer said in that moment he
honestly believed he was about to be
stabbed
the officers opened fire simultaneously
bringing the young terrorist knife
rampage to a halt
62 seconds after it began mark white sky
news